I always love putting like making videos
like just kind of putting together short
funny sketches and stuff like that like
I started when I was like a lot younger
like not a lot I'm gonna be like in high
school I would just kind of shut up like
a like a MacBook camera you know and
then I just like film myself saying like
one one or two stupid lines and then I'd
be like like hey Erik or Kylie they say
just say something stupid and then
they'd say something and then I just
like cut it and make like the most
random little stupid videos but they're
still kind of funny you know just
because we're improving them and stuff
like in high school I did TV production
and I can I made like you know short
little videos and stuff that were
supposed to be news stories but I always
just tried to make them into like
they're pretty much sketches you know
but they're supposed to be news stories
so might be my TV production two tries
but it heads could she just hated me but
that was like what I started kind of
getting into making little you know
because the whole concept of like making
little short three-minute sketches is
relatively new you know like no one
really with construction of YouTube
that's kind of like what started it you
know other than like Saturday Night Live
and stuff like that but I've always
watched Saturday Night Live as a kid so
I it's just something that I've always
really liked during I like making people
laugh and I saw YouTube as a good way to
just kind of start getting my stuff out
there I didn't know you know when I
started that it was you're supposed to
do like a weekly video and really not
hold form at work but I just wanted to
start somewhere with like the videos and
start getting working towards you start
working towards building a fan base so
that I could have that because I didn't
know you know the specific ways that you
go about being a partner but stuff like
that so I just kind of wanted to start
out with like you know get some fans and
then I was hoping that you know the
partnership thing would just kind of
come which is which is sort of did but
it's a hard it was it was a big you know
it's like all right here we go I'm gonna
start making a video a week and I'm
promising a video
cuz you know when you have that many
people counting on a video every week
you can't you can't let him down I
wasn't really ever planning on on
focusing on on frat life I was uh I
thought that first video that I made
would be a good a good kind of jumpstart
to starting the channel up just because
I knew how vital it could go because
it's such a relatable video everyone
knows that frat douchebag
he's in every fraternity you know so I
knew I knew and I like you know it took
me so long all the quotes in that video
I was like composing over the like the
whole semester I was writing them down
like a notepad and those are like the
funniest quotes and then at the end of
it I was like I can easily make this
into a viral video but then you know of
course and I saw it wasn't really
necessarily planning on doing multiple
frat videos I was hoping it would just
be the one and then you know after that
I would be able to start doing you know
my awkward social interactions or just
like funny sketch comedy but of course
you know you gotta confess what the fans
want and a lot of the fans want frat
videos but you know it's time it's times
going on getting there getting less and
less of them and I think cuz you know
college is gonna end eventually so I can
I can't focus on frat videos forever but
for now they're funny for now they're
funny and they're fun to do I want to
say a specific person but a lot of a lot
of the quotes were kind of jokes that I
would make about a certain individual in
our fraternity it was just so ridiculous
when we were when I was pleasuring he
was just like the most he was insane you
know he was out of his mind and he was
just like what I saw as to the typical
the typical frat guy you know and
everyone thought it was funny everyone
got a big kick out of it and we're
actually really good friends now being
him but uh it was just funny because he
was uh when we were pleasures you know
he obviously wasn't cool with us
so we would always you know you'd leave
the room and then we start you know
joking around [ __ ] we just make you
just be making fun of them then like you
know say stupid things and that's like
where you know the lines like you know
well were you gonna go you're gonna go
choose your shots with muscle no Pro
like you know one of the things I said
and then you know I just like write it
down my notepad I don't like those kind
of a good joke I'm gonna write that down
put that in the video later because you
know you got to take a step back
sometime from the fraternity and just
realize how ridiculous some of the
things that you're doing are you know
like you're just like wow and you're
like wow okay I'm gonna there's gonna be
aware of this situation and just you
know not not get to not just lose my
mind here
very easy to get brainwashed in the
whole you know fraternity thing get to
get too crazy with it but you know it's
got to find a good balance I get a kick
out a wife you know I think everyday
situations there's there's so many funny
things that happens that like people
just kind of accept it as as everyday
life but there's some situations that
are really funny to exploit that just
kind of happened like so casually like
all those awkward social interactions
videos are based on you know things yeah
tall things that actually happen all the
time I just think it's really funny like
awkward I think awkward things are
really funny when someone's like when
something's happening you know that's
just kind of like ridiculous and it's
like one guy is doing it or whatever I'm
not really sure what I'm talking about
right now but like one guy's doing it
and then like you know the people you're
with you're just kind of giving those
looks like what the hell is going on you
know it's those kind of moments that I
like to just exploit and just be like
make it into a video because you know
most of the time when you look at the
person next year and you guys are both
like
that's how everybody else feels you know
so it's like everybody else is looking
at each other like yeah this is totally
this is totally relatable so I was like
exploiting like everyday situations and
that that actually happens to people
that I just think is so funny I've
always wanted to really collaborate with
good neighbor stuff I've always thought
they're hilarious since I saw the all
those like you know my roommate is I
think my roommate is gay one and like
all those all those videos with Kyle and
you just I just thought he was so all
those interviews and you guys I thought
those were so hilarious
well I'm uh I'm planning on moving back
to LA full time even though I live in LA
I just go to school in Arizona but I'm
uh I'm moving back here full time this
summer and you know for now YouTube is
like a full-time job that I can just
have until you know I have something
else that that you know takes the place
of YouTube you know financially and
timewise but I'm trying to uh you know
maybe maybe get a show maybe be on the
show maybe maybe uh growing up shoes
coming out in July so I'm excited for
that and then we're working on that
total frat movie I was telling you about
so it's gonna be fun just trying to get
as many as many projects and stuff going
as I can
we're working on we're still working on
the
this script and and all that stuff and
promoting it and that but it's called
the total frappe movie and we are trying
to shoot it in August I believe so we're
just trying to get everything taken care
of right now and I was I was recently
added to the team not recently I mean
there's been we've been you know in
contact with him for the past couple
months but we had a few meetings as of
lately that really kind of as I got
let's do this down so now I'm now I'm on
board
yeah working towards making that as
funny as possible we're hoping it's
gonna be the like the next National
Lampoon series kind of thing or like
American Pie or something like that
so I'm gonna help make it as funny as
possible well that about wraps it up I'm
Jimmy tatra thanks for checking out this
video you can check out the whole
interview and photo shoot at a new media
rockstars calm but make sure to
subscribe to life cornea Jimmy